salut bon dimanche c'est le jour des
explications je vous apprends quelque
chose que vous allez pouvoir faire à
d'autres personnes pour les bluffer pour
les mentaliser et là je vais vous faire
plaisir parce qu'on va parler légèrement
très légèrement mais un petit peu quand
même dit close je vous propose que vous
fassiez un jupe nautique sur une autre
personne pour vous rendre contre vous
déjà de ce que c'est un petit peu
l'hypnose et pour mentaliser vos cobayes
différemment que d'habitude je vous
explique tout la procédure pas à pas
mais sachez que vous pouvez le faire sur
vous-même aussi en auto hypnose ça
fonctionne avec un discours intérieur
expliquez à votre collègue du jour que
vous allez faire un jeu et nautiques
c'est à dire c'est pas vraiment de
l'hypnose c'est juste pour jouer c'est
quelque chose qui est très positif pour
lui vous lui demander de se détendre un
petit peu et surtout de jouer le jeu
mentalement s'ils ne jouent pas le jeu
mentalement alors ça ne fonctionnera pas
sera même pas la peine d'essayer
dans ce jeu hypnotique tout le monde
doit mettre un petit peu de bonne
volonté vous lui demander de se détendre
et de fixer un point au loin un point où
il pourrait aller accrocher sa main si
jamais il se déplacer il doit réellement
10u alizés ce point complètement il doit
même imaginer dans sa tête comment ils
feraient pour s'y accrocher
ça peut être un montant de porte ça peut
être l'angle d'un mur peu importe une
fois que c'est fait vous lui demander de
fermer les yeux là personne ne doit
fermer les une fois que la personne a
les yeux fermés vous allez lui expliquer
qu'au moment où elle va ouvrir les yeux
elle va s'imaginer réellement
mentalement en se répétant je vais
m'accrocher qu'elle va réussir à étendre
son bras pour s'accrocher mentalement au
point qu'elle a fixés pour que ça
fonctionne vous pouvez lui expliquer
qu'il faut vraiment qu'elle mettre sa
main dans laxe dans l'angle de vue pour
avoir l'illusion jeu de visuels qu'elle
s'accroche réellement dites lui de
mettre réellement son bras en tension et
qu'elle s'imagine vraiment être accroché
là bas ne doit fixer que son objectif
donc son regard doit être axé uniquement
au contact visuel de la main et du point
qu'elle a défini pour s'accrocher et
mentalement elle doit se répéter en
boucle je suis fermement accroché rien
ne peut plier mon bras je suis fermement
accroché rien et publier mon bras elle
doit donc se met dans un état de
concentration est votre rôle c'est de
l'aider à sa de la guider de lui répéter
en permanence que son bras est accrochée
quand rien ne peut le plier son bras est
réellement accroché
rien ne peut le nier vous devez l'aider
à se concentrer là dessus et à ne pas
détourner son attention à l'autre focus
du regard est très important elle ne
doit jamais lâché ce point de contact
comme ça elle doit tout le temps le
regarder tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps jamais ailleurs et au bout
d'une ou deux minutes voire même
quelques secondes pour les plus
efficaces vous allez pouvoir vous amuser
à essayer de plier son bras se sera pas
possible
allez-y vraiment franchement essayer de
toutes vos forces de plier la personne
cru
vous pliez plus elle doit se convaincre
qu'elle est accrochée là bas qu'elle est
physiquement accroché sans lâcher le
point de vue qui va bloquer ses muscles
plus fermement que ce qu'elle arriverait
à faire consciemment si vous êtes
plusieurs vous pouvez demander à des
amis à vous de vous aider à plier le
bras de la personne vous allez voir une
résistance hors norme par rapport à ce
que je pourrais faire habituellement
comme je vous le disais au tout départ
vous pouvez le faire aussi sur vous même
en vous mettant dans cet état de
concentration et de focus en vous
répétant mentalement que vous êtes
réellement approcher et là vous demandez
à deux personnes décédées depuis votre
bras ce sera pas possible
j'espère sincèrement que ce petit tour
du dimanche un petit peu différente
d'habitude vous aura plu
vous le savez sur la chaîne c'est step
by step donc je vous réserve encore pas
mal de surprises n'oubliez pas que j'ai
organisé une faq pour fêter les trente
mille abonnés c'est la faq que je ferais
je dis donc posé moi vos questions
jusqu'à mercredi soir sur twitter avec
le hashtag mentalisme 30000 ça fait un
petit peu supermarché discount
mais le hashtag me faisait rire et j'ai
vu qu'il y en a qui avait déjà posé
leurs questions c'est parfait si cette
vidéo vous a plu alors dans ces cas là
vous n'entendez que le son de ma voix et
vous focalisez sur un magnifique et
tétanisant pouce en l'air
n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit
commentaire vous le savez en ce moment
je réponds un petit peu moins que
d'habitude mais je les lis toujours tous
comme vous pouvez le constater quand
vous me posez une question très
importante là je prends quelques
secondes pour le faire donc je suis
toujours présent je suis en train de
préparer les vidéos là pour cet été ça
me prend énormément de temps n'oubliez
pas également de vous abonner avant de
partir puisque le mental blog c'est une
vidéo par jour pendant un an depuis le
1er janvier donc rendez vous demain à
17h ciao